this is the Sinclair zx81 it's a
computer produced by now Sir Clive
Sinclair and launched in 1981
hence the 81 part of it it's a really
really important machine and one that is
hugely misunderstood and unfairly
treated in my opinion this is a machine
that I had in 81 as a kid we got it
delivered albeit late as most people and
and we built it as that kid is quite a
simple board just a single board inside
that you sold it together and plug in
this whole keyboard mechanism overlay at
the front and you had a computer with
the full 1k of memory what's really
important about it is the price so it
gets ridiculed because it had a number
of drawbacks and deficiencies but
nothing else touched you on price okay
this was the first machine you could
really go out to the high street and buy
from somebody like boots or WH Smiths
and that was a big deal so he's no
longer looking in the backs of
electronics magazines this was walking
down the high street oh look there's a
home computer should we buy one and
people did they bought a lot of them and
that was about the price so this machine
was sub 100 pound to my knowledge about
the first machine that actually took
that price point and that made it
although it's still quite a bit of money
you know you had to think about it
wasn't just sort of throw away money it
was something that people were kind of
encouraged to buy the government was
talking about computers and how they
were going to be the future and for once
the government was right and and you
know everything was about you know
moving ahead and getting computers into
our lives and there's X 81 was the cheap
way of doing a relatively cheap we're
doing it so this is the machine that's
what you had when you built it all up
it has a very cheap membrane keyboard so
no moving parts to it really you can
just touch the buttons there it has a
simple circuit board inside just one
circuit board with all the components on
and it had this connector at the back
which allows you to increase it to a
massive 16 K of memory with that Ram
pack which quite famously it sort of
suffered from when RAM pack wobble so
one should plug the the pack in at the
back there if it moved at any point
while you were typing your code it would
lose the connections lose the memory and
you'd have to start all over again and
if you typed in C 16 K of code that was
slightly annoying so you'd have a
cassette player most people in their
homes at the time had a cassette player
but they were using for their music and
you could buy programs on those tapes
and load them in from tape so that was
feasible you tended to spend ages just
getting the volume exactly right there
would be a pattern on the screen and
that would tell you whether that black
and white bars and the width of the bars
would tell you whether it's about right
but even when it was right a half the
time it well not half sometimes it
failed and you'd have to start again I
think we tend to give it a hard time
from that point of view I think it works
a lot more than we remember you just
remember those times where it let you
down there was no monitor for it as such
you hopefully as a spare TV in the
dining room or kicked you maybe a little
black and white screen like this and
you'd plug it in to the aerial socket of
the TV and you'd have a power adapter
that gives it nine volts and you plug it
in screen goes blank for a second and we
should end up with a little K in the
bottom corner so that K there is telling
us it's really fractured very minimal
booting up time the little delay as we
plug the e/m was it testing the memory
actually if you did the same thing
without the memory the K appeared pretty
much instantly so that was just a little
memory test that was doing but once you
had that you're ready to go so you had a
look at the manual it was a very very
good menu actually and in the manual
there's all these little example
programs that went through basic basic
was the language that it used stands for
beginners all-purpose symbolic
instruction code I've got a feeling that
was kind of retrofitted to the word
basic round the other way around but
anyway and and most home computers at
that time used basic as their as the
language but you've had these little
example programs and you type them in
see what they did maybe understand what
they did change it for yourself make it
do something you wanted it to do and for
me that was my first foray into actual
programming typing in the demonstrations
then modifying them to do what I wanted
to do and for most people their first
program would be something along these
lines so 10 and they're quite
interesting the way you enter the data
because you would think there you type
in print PR int but actually all you do
is press the P key and it has something
called a tokenized basic so it didn't
store all these letters it just stored
the one token for the
print command which allows you to get
more programming into a small space
you've got these commands that are
written above the keys and that made
typing things in that little bit quicker
before this keyboard that was kind of
important so then I would type in
something like Jason is great and you
press newline to enter it and it would
jump up to the top of the screen and
that line of code is now in there and
the next line probably everybody
watching is gonna be practically singing
this because everybody knows it it's
like go to 10 so our first line of code
says Jason is great 20 go to 10 so then
line 20 would go back to line 10 and we
type him run or press R for run and
press return and there you go screen
full of whatever it was for a lot of
people it would be going into Dickson's
of a Saturday morning or WH Smiths or
boots or whatever they'd have one of
these on display the method will be
somewhat ruder and you would type that
in press run and leggett and a lot of
people is there they're fond memories of
their first use of computers but you
know as simple as that is we're still
teaching that code here in the museum
today to scroll groups that come in and
they love it you know it's this media
you do that you type it in and it runs
and they think well actually I wanted to
say something else so they change it and
now they're typing in code and they're
making that code their own and then
maybe they get it to count or there are
all sorts of things from there but
that's a really good starting point and
probably for most people that
programmers that's the first thing they
ever typed in it was cheap and that was
the most important thing about it yeah
you could afford to buy one of these
machine it didn't have the capacity of
the other machines that would come later
or even before and it was you know made
cheap in every single way possible and
that was both the beauty of it and also
the curse you know it did take a lot of
stick because it wasn't a proper
computer but actually it really was and
it did change things for a lot of people
we'd like to thank Squarespace for this
episode of computerphile the hang on I
know what you're thinking but they don't
just do paint-by-numbers websites
computer files might want to check out
their developer platform and if you
enter the code computer file you'll get
10% off I put together a website on the
Squarespace and I know that as well as
looking great it's also going to be
fully configurable they start at $8 a
month and if you sign up for a year
they'll give you a free domain name
what's really cool is there's no need
for any credit card details to get
started just sign up and start building
so thanks once again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this computerphile video
remember
enter the code computerphile for 10% off
is the big reveal so this is the
internals of our serial number 3 and
it's quite drastically different